So let's say that there are missing values
in your data and they're distributed at random. What
do we do? There are two approaches that I
want to discuss here, partial deletion and impution. Partial
deletion is exactly what it sounds like, limiting our
data set for analysis to the data that we
have available to us. Let's discuss partial deletion further.
For the following discussion let's use the Sean Lawman
database of baseball players. There are a number of
players for whom many values are missing. Now let's
say that we wanted to ask a couple of
different questions. For example what are the average life span
and average height of baseball players? There are many
players that we can't include in the analysis, either because
their birth date or death date is missing, or
because they're still alive. In this case, we may want
to perform partial deletion. One method we could
use is called Listwise Deletion. In the case
where we perform Listwise Deletion, we'd exclude a
particular data point from all analyses even if
some useful values were present. So if using
Listwise Deletion, Barry Bonds, who has a listed
height, but not death date, would not be
included in either analysis, even if we were calculating
the average height of players. On the other hand,
in the case where we might perform Pairwise Deletion,
we would exclude a particular case from the analysis
for tasks which are not possible with the data
at hand. So we wouldn't include Barry Bonds in
our sample when calculating life span since there's no
death date, but we would still use his height
when calculating the average height of all baseball players.